I am so excited to be here today because
it means I haven't been deported yet so
yes I from Texas but nowadays you never
know it's frightening um I was ok I was
a little bummed after the election but I
thought it was gonna be ok
until the day after when I started
getting all these phone calls and texts
from my white friends making sure I was
ok
nothing scares the hell out of you than
having white people worried about your
future that's when you know things are
really serious you know they send me
calls like hey cristela
we tried don't worry it gets better
hey cristela look our thoughts are with
you ok let me know if you're ok I'm like
it was that running against him like is
that why he won cuz I didn't campaign at
all right and then I started thinking
you know what I'm gonna do the same
thing back to them every time I see
something that I think is gonna scare
white people I'm gonna call my friends
make sure they're OK like hey Bryce hey
I saw the season finale to Big Bang
Theory's on tonight my thoughts are with
you hey Stacy I went to the grocery
store you better sit down they're out of
hummus
I went to the women's March in DC a
couple weeks ago that was really hard
thank you I don't want to call me a hero
but you just did so I'll take it
it was really cool to be there
surrounded by hundreds of thousands of
women wearing like the pink cat hats
that they crocheted and you know like
the posters with glitter and stuff it
was like a walking Etsy store you know
and I was so I've never protested before
I've never marched like I've never
marched right
I was so swept up in it like it was
powerful because these women they
brought their a-game right like their
chant game a plus some of the chants
started off really simple you know like
I'm gay iein gay don't take our rights
away got it I learned right my favorite
one was hey we can't build a wall
because Trump's hands are small
whoever did that like she is our
generations Maya Angelou you know what I
mean like magic right but that got me so
energized I want to do a chant myself
right so I got so swept up in it I'm
like hey trunk
don't forget realize I don't know
anything to rhyme with forget right they
start thinking well cristela why are you
marching equality damn that's a hard
word to rhyme why are you marching and I
said go with it now Mike hey trunk don't
forget
trying to hit my Fitbit steps I don't
because I want to fight for equal rights
but I want to lose a couple pounds too
you know and that's what I realized
you guys I think I'm a bad woman like
I'm a bad feminist for sure like first
of all feminism gives me low self-esteem
can we take it down a notch the other
day I was reading an article this woman
was complaining about catcalling right
she's like hey I'm sick and tired of
people objectifying me these men they
yell at me they treat me like a piece of
meat it has to stop now first thing I
thought wasn't like hell yeah sisterhood
first thing I thought was why does no
one cat call me in my life
I want to go out into the street and be
like someone objectify me look at my
shirt it's kind of tight a couple weeks
ago I was in New York I was standing at
a street corner right and all I hear is
a mommy and I'm thinking oh damn it's
gonna happen I turn around and he's like
hey the light just turned red you're
gonna get hit by a car come back am I
the only woman that gets catcalled
useful information nothing about my body
nothing
I'm the only woman that gets catcalled
lifehacks hey baby hey mommy
don't forget to file your taxes
tomorrow's April 15
[Applause]
you